I really like that last demo where we
turn circles into squares it really
shows the awesome power of style and
also represents that everything on a
webpage is actually a box but why is it
so important to really understand that
concept you might be thinking to
yourself hey I'm not a square I'm
actually a really cool person and I
don't like to think about boxes but
actually thinking of the things in terms
of boxes makes your life as a front-end
web developer a lot easier take an
example website here we have many
different elements images text a header
and by thinking of things in terms of
boxes we can actually easily rearrange
things if we decide to give the users a
different experience say for example we
don't want to keep the text up here we
want more pictures of puppies because
users like more pictures and might not
want to read the text so we'll take away
the text here move some cute pictures of
puppies up here and then put the text
along the bottom now readers can read
the text if they'd like to or just look
at cute pictures of puppies there's also
a grid in the background which serves to
make sure that everything is properly
aligned but we'll talk more about that
in lesson 2